what is what is critical theory i don't
know what critical theory is
critical theory is a way to view the
world um
the long and short of it is that it's a
way to view the world that sees the
world
in terms of so then there are multiple
critical theories there are many
critical theories
um at its very bottom it's a way to view
the world
where everything relevant in terms of
at least of social relations has to do
with
power dynamics that are in society
between some group
with power and other groups who don't
have as much power
and the object of critical theory is to
say that the groups that have power
carry certain assumptions
and biases and the likes
and they bake that into the systems that
they create without realizing that
they're doing it so the critical
theorists job
is to expose those biases and uncover
those
assumptions so that they can be
critiqued and re-examined and
usually discarded dismantled subverted
or
otherwise overthrown so you would have
this in the marxist
sense the power group would either be
the capitalists or the bourgeoisie which
would be a property holding class
and they you know in a kind of a very
direct sense
control the working class and kind of
control how they're supposed to think
and set the fashion and set the tone
of what high society is supposed to look
like or how the
businesses are supposed to be operated
and they exploit
the working class which would be the
oppressed group um
critical theory uh grew out of that
mindset
in what the institute for social
research that was set up in frankfurt
germany in the 20s
that's now called the frankfurt school
um
and they actually following off of the
italian communist philosopher
antonio gramsci realized that you know
marx
predicted there would be this revolution
the proletariat would rise up and
overthrow the capitalists and the
bourgeoisie and this didn't happen
and they wanted to know why so antonio
gramsci came up with this idea
that's called cultural hegemony and
that's the idea that the
powerful classes of society set the way
that everybody's supposed to think
and everybody else buys into that so
they won't go against it
and then the frankfurt school kind of
ran with this idea
and started saying that things like
liberalism and western civilization
themselves bake in the assumptions of
their creators
and make it so that
the people who have power which would
mostly be
white western men who are straight and
so on
have both explicitly and inadvertently
cooked up systems of power so that they
benefit themselves
and exclude those that they don't want
to take to have the power because it
powers a zero sum object in this world
view so
um critical theory is
in that sense a way of looking at the
world that sees the world that way
and that essentially tries to pick at
whatever the system is
so as to tear apart the hidden
assumptions and biases that's the most
charitable way to put it that's what
they say that they're doing is tearing
apart the hidden assumptions and biases
to make the system more fair or as they
phrased it in
the front for school to make it into an
ideal democracy
um where nobody is actually
uh has their voice or their opportunity
or whatever shortchanged so
that's a very long definition um but at
face value that sounds critical theory
sounds
pretty good uh it it's
definitely something that when used
appropriately a critical method at least
can be very very useful and in fact um
the enlightenment tradition which has
brought us you know pretty much all of
modernity like the ability to skype and
have good microphones and things
the enlightenment tradition could very
easily be
seen as an appropriate use of critical
methods it started to
question the authority of say the church
and it started to
say let's defer to an external authority
the essentially the the way nature works
to answer our questions about the world
and let's try to appeal to
reason and logic and
[Music]
evidence as much as we can in making our
decisions and so
it started to create this very different
way to see the world
that presented a very useful skepticism
against the previous kind of
mythological
and uh episcopate type
and monarchical type mindsets where you
had these
literally powerful individuals who then
decided
you know either the interpretation of
scripture or the organization of society
or whatever and whatever their fancy was
was how
it went you know the the law was what
the king said the law was or
you know the scripture is that the pope
interpret
interprets it to say and so on so
yes um the issue is that a critical
theory there
so this philosopher um max horkheimer
in the frankfurt school laid out the
difference between what's technically
called
a critical theory and what he called a
traditional theory
both of which exist within a broader
kind of critical thinking tradition that
we would think of
and the point of a traditional theory is
to understand a thing
is just to understand it the point of a
critical theory is to understand
how it goes wrong and in particular how
it goes wrong
according to some normative vision which
means
a moral structure and
how to qualify as a critical theory it
must be
explanatory about how it is
particularly an unjust thing so it's
looking for injustices
in the system and nothing else no
attempt to understand how the thing
works
necessarily or why those injustices
happen to be what they are or something
like this
and it must fit the vision of the
social engineers who are have decided
what justice looks like
when they look for these injustices and
it must be applicable by
activists and so it is
in a sense a way of putting the cart
ahead of
the horse where you know our our
best knowledge should lead our decision
making
rather than what we want to be true
leading
our approach to figuring out knowledge
yeah
so yes the best way that i can think of
it is to actually because i don't want
to say that critical theory is
useless because it's not um
it's odd that it gets applied to so much
given that it's mostly a literary thing
but um i try to say that it's like a
really strong industrial solvent
um it has applications it has uses but
man you're not going to spread it
everywhere
you're not going to give it to kids
you're not going to just you know dump
it on everything you see
um it's one of those things that
certainly has
beneficial and appropriate uses uh we
should be looking for those
biases and those un considered
assumptions but we should also do so
responsibly not
with an effort only to pick at how
something goes wrong you must also
understand
why the system your situation is the way
that it is
[Music]